Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 47. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe hier rund um die Raumfahrt in Deutschland und Europa. Und ja, heute geht es, wie man sich schon hat denken können, wenn man die letzte Folge gehört hat, um die Venus, einen unserer acht Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem, und nachdem wir letztes Mal über Venus Express gesprochen haben, also der Mission, der ESA, die aktuelle Mission der ESA zu diesem Planeten, wollen wir jetzt mal ein wenig tiefer eintauchen in die Realitäten und die wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse, die bisher gewonnen werden konnten und die man vielleicht in Zukunft noch gewinnen wird über diesen Planeten. Und dazu habe ich natürlich wieder mal den Weg nach Berlin Adlershof angetreten, ins Institut für Planetenforschung des DLR. Und spreche heute mit Jörn, Jörn Helbert. Hallo, guten Tag. Du bist hier im Institut in der Abteilung experimentelle Planetenphysik untergebracht.
Richtig.
Was muss man sich darunter vorstellen? Was kann man so aus der Ferne experimentell mit einem Planeten anstellen?
Wir stellen wenig aus der Ferne an, sondern wir versuchen hier im Labor die Planeten nachzustellen, um einen Vergleich zu dem zu haben, was wir dann aus der Ferne sehen. Wir haben verschiedene Labore hier, in denen wir Bedingungen auf Planeten simulieren und gleiche Messungen machen, wie das, was wir von den Missionen zurückbekommen. Einfach um einen Vergleich zu haben, was macht das eigentlich? Was sehen wir da wirklich im Vergleich zu dem, was wir auf der Erde zum Beispiel kennen?
Wie kann man so einen ganzen Planeten nachstellen?
Einen ganzen Planeten kann man gar nicht nachstellen, man kann sich bestimmte Eigenschaften rauspicken, wie eine dünne Atmosphäre oder wie die richtige Temperatur und versuchen das nachzustellen im Vergleich zu der eigentlichen Planeten-Oberfläche.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt, hier gibt es nicht nur Büros, wo man Papier wählt, sondern hier gibt es auch richtige Labore mit entsprechenden Einrichtungen.
Richtige Labore mit ganz viel Geräten, ganz viel Krach und wo man richtig sich die Hände dreckig macht und noch die Rolle Klebeband in die Hand nimmt.
Also was sind das für Geräte? Vakuumkammern oder?
Genau, was wir hier haben, sind eine ganze Reihe von Spektrometern, die im sichtbaren, nahenverrotten Bereich Spektren aufnehmen, verbunden mit verschiedenen Kammern, Vakuumkammern, Hochtemperaturkammern in unserem Fall. Und wo wir dann verschiedene Bedingungen nachstellen können und eine große Sammlung von Gesteinen, die wir eben dann nehmen, als Vergleich zu dem, was wir auf Planeten sehen.
Und ist das jetzt nur, um selber so Dinge nachvollziehen zu können oder hat das auch was mit der Entwicklung von Instrumenten zu tun für Missionen?
Das ist beides. Also was wir hier machen, ist zum einen eben, dass wir nachvollziehen können, was wir dann auf dem Planeten sehen. Und zum anderen ist es, wenn wir für neue Instrumente Entwicklungen vorantreiben, dass wir eben sehen können, was muss ein Instrument eigentlich können, was müssen wir mindestens sehen können, damit wir überhaupt irgendeine Aussage machen können über eine Planetenoberfläche.
Das heißt, man macht sowohl Experimente, um so ein bisschen nach vorne zu schauen, mit was werden wir messen können, was sind die Anforderungen an ein Instrument, werden die Instrumente auch selber dann hier getestet?
Wir testen auch zum Teil die Instrumente selber hier. Genau richtig. Im Idealfall, im Traumfall, wie man das ja selten hinbekommt, würde man halt vorher die ganzen Gesteine vermessen haben. Und dann, wenn man am Planeten ankommt, kann man direkt vergleichen mit dem, was wir vorher gemessen haben und kann sofort was sagen. Der Normalfall ist, dass wir an den Planeten ankommen und dann anfangen parallel ganz schnell im Labor zu messen, um zu verstehen, was wir da gerade gesehen haben. Aber für die Instrumenteentwicklung, für die Instrumente, die wir selber bauen hier im Haus, machen wir eben tatsächlich die Arbeiten vorher und tragen dann eben auch die Instrumente ins Labor und lassen die Instrumente selber dann mal auf das schauen, was wir hier im Labor haben, um eine Idee zu bekommen, wie gut sie dann funktionieren. Nur, dass wir dann nachher sehen werden, dass wir dann nicht überrascht sind, was das Instrument da plötzlich an Daten zeigt.
Aber wahrscheinlich wird man auch nicht selten dann mal auf einmal Messdaten bekommen von irgendwelchen Missionen, wo man sich fragt, so, hm, dann muss man das irgendwie nochmal nachstellen, irgendwie, um das vergleichen zu können.
Das ist ja genau gerade das Spannende daran. Sonst wäre es ja langweilig, wenn man ankommt und sagt, naja, gut, das ist das, was ich erwartet habe. Und das Spannende ist, man kommt an, sieht Daten und stellt fest, hm, das passt überhaupt nicht mit dem zusammen, was ich mir vorher gedacht habe. Aber dann ist das Schöne halt, wir können hier dann in die nächste Tür ins Labor gehen und sagen, na okay, wenn es, keine Ahnung, Schwefel sein soll, dann lass uns mal gucken, wie Schwefel aussieht und ob es das sein kann oder nicht. Und das ist eine der großen Sachen, einer der großen Vorteile, die wir hier haben, dass wir die Sachen selber messen können. Das heißt, wir müssen nicht irgendjemand anders fragen, sondern wir können wirklich morgens ins Labor rübergehen und mal einen Planeten vermessen. Genau. Mal eine neue verrückte Idee vermessen und einfach gucken und dann relativ schnell sagen, ja, das kann sein oder nein, das kann nicht sein.
Okay, also es ist ja sehr viel mehr Interaktivität in dem ganzen Geschehen, als man sich vielleicht manchmal so denkt.
Ja, bei uns hier auf jeden Fall. Das ist so, wie wir unsere Gruppe aufgebaut haben, dass wir eben die Interaktivität haben und dass wir eben tatsächlich Sachen einfach stumpf ausprobieren können. In dem Fall ist das halt eben das Experimental an unserer Gruppe, dass man eben die Sachen auch wirklich dann mal einfach ausprobiert.
Wie ist denn jetzt dein eigener Weg gewesen, bis du hierher gekommen bist? Wie lange bist du schon hier am DLR?
Ich bin inzwischen 14 Jahre am DLR.
Und ist da viel anderes vorher passiert?
Ja, ich habe in Braunschweig Physik studiert. Damals noch gar nicht so richtig mit der Aussicht, mal was für Planeten zu machen, sondern eigentlich, weil ich Physik spannend fand.
Wobei ja Raumfahrt eine große Rolle zu spielen scheint, in der Universität in Braunschweig.
Ja, richtig, aber das ist die Raumfahrtechnik. Also ich war damals tatsächlich in der richtigen echten Physik, habe ganze theoretische Physik alles echt voll durchgemacht. Hatte zwar immer eine Faszination für Planetenastronomie, aber war dann auch realistisch genug zu sagen, da gibt es so wenig Stellen, das wird eh nie was werden. Aber Physik ist ein guter Einstieg. Und hatte dann aber das große Glück, dass ich dann irgendwann in der Mitte des Studiums mal ein Seminar machen sollte über Planeten. Und es war damals über eine Zusammenfassung über Mars-Missionen. Und das habe ich dann gemacht und habe festgestellt, dass es so unglaublich spannend ist. Das will ich doch probieren da reinzukommen. Und habe dann noch eine Diplomarbeit gemacht zu einer Mission in der Erdumlaufbahn. Habe dann auch gleich gelernt, wie hart das Geschäft ist, weil die Mission ist beim Start explodiert. Das heißt also, meine Diplomarbeit war dann eine sehr theoretische Arbeit. Weil eigentlich war das ein Programm...
Das heißt, du hast die Diplomarbeit schon vorher geplant gehabt über die Mission?
Ich habe die Diplomarbeit, ich war vier Monate in meiner Diplomarbeit, hatte das Programm, was die Daten auswerten sollte, fertig. Und hätte dann eigentlich die Daten auswerten sollen. Und dann ist der Satellit explodiert. Das war dann so das harte Training, wie denn das Geschäft aussehen könnte. Damit war auch meine Doktorarbeit damals dann explodiert und musste was Neues finden. Und dadurch bin ich zum DLR gekommen. Weil die halt damals eine Doktorarbeit ausgeschrieben hatten zu Kometenphysik und Kometenforschung. Und dadurch bin ich ins DLR gekommen und dann hier hängen geblieben. Viele Zwischenstationen im DLR, verschiedene Situationen. Ich war im Ausland, ich war für die Doktorarbeiten teil und auch danach noch mal, aber dann meine Basis ist...
Im Ausland jetzt bei einer DLR-Niederlassung oder was?
Nee, ich war in den USA am South West Research Institute, hab da ein Teil meiner Doktorarbeit gemacht. Ich war in der Braun University, nachher für Forschungsarbeiten dann. Also relativ viel in Providence in New England. Mit USA automatisch, das war das halt bei unserem Geschäft. Der Hauptpartner ist aber Japan auch. Aber DLR ist halt seit 14 Jahren jetzt meine Hauptbasis.
Also hast du einiges gesehen. Wie hieß denn dieser Planet, der explodiert ist?
Das war die Cluster-Mission. Die dann ja tatsächlich nochmal neu geflogen ist, aber das war damals natürlich nicht abzusehen, dass es das nochmal neu geben würde.
Ja, gut. Bist du denn im Rahmen deiner Tätigkeit hier jetzt auf bestimmte Planeten festgelegt? Oder kommt man hier eigentlich mit allem in Berührung?
Man kommt eigentlich mit fast allem in Berührung. Bei mir ist es mehr eine Festlegung. Ich bin ja in meiner Geschichte im DLR von Kometen zum Mars gewandert, vom Mars zum Merkur und dann parallel zur Venus. Also ich hab das innere Sonnensystem einmal durchgemacht in meiner Karriere hier im DLR. Und bei mir ist es mehr eine Frage der Technik.
Aber der Asteroidengürtel hast du nie überschritten?
Zumindest nicht aktiv bis jetzt. Ich hab zwar mal Ideen, aber ich hab nie was wirklich außerhalb des Asteroidengürtels gearbeitet. Also wirklich innere Sonnensystem bis zum Mars raus. Und bei mir ist es eigentlich mehr durch die Technik. Also dass ich halt Infrarotspektroskopie mache. Das ist halt das, was mich treibt. Und welche immer Körper dann in Frage kommt, ist halt dann nicht egal. Weil es ist in jeder Körper spannend. Aber die Technik ist das, was eigentlich das ist, was bei mir das verbindet dann.
Ja, die Venus ist ja hier wieder ein weiterer Beitrag zur allgemeinen Romantik. In gewisser Hinsicht so. Ist ja auch so einer dieser Gestirne, die die Fantasie halt schon immer weit beflügelt hat. Der Morgenstern oder auch der Abendstern. Also auf jeden Fall auch ein extrem sichtbares und von daher auch von der Menschheit sehr früh wahrgenommenes Gestirn. Ich weiß nicht, wie weit muss man denn so in die Vergangenheit blicken, wenn man so nachvollziehen will, wie die Menschheit die Venus nachvollzogen hat?
Das kommt drauf an, wie weit man zurückgehen will, aber das Bild der Venus hat sich über die letzten 200, 300 Jahre ganz massiv gewandelt. Also, da man klar war, dass es ein Planet ist und dass es eben nicht ein Stern ist, gab es viele verschiedene Ideen. Und es war ja eigentlich relativ schnell klar, als man angefangen hat zu vermessen die Position der Planeten, dass die Venus relativ nah zu uns ist und ein bisschen näher an der Sonne dran ist. Und da gab es halt viele Ideen, dass es halt ein erdähnlicher Planet ist und ein bisschen wärmer, tropisch, aber im Großen und Ganzen doch vergleichbar mit dem, was wir hier auf der Erde haben. Und es gab einen ganz spannenden Wettstreit vor 150, 200 Jahren, glaube ich, wo man versucht hat, die Rotationsperiode der Venus zu bestimmen durch beobachtende Oberfläche.
Also wie sehr sich die Venus um sich selbst...
Genau, richtig. Und da gab es halt verschiedene Forscher, die versucht haben, das immer genauer, auf die Minute genau zu bestimmen. Was man natürlich heute weiß, dass sie nie die Oberfläche sehen konnten, weil das sind die Wolken dazwischen. Aber die haben das halt in großem Wettstreit untereinander betrieben, wer denn die genaueste Rotationsrate herausbekommt und was man denn alles auf der Oberfläche gesehen hat. Was man heute weiß, sie konnten gar nicht auf der Oberfläche sehen. Und die Venus ist halt einer der Planeten, wo dann tatsächlich Missionen das Bild massiv geändert haben. Weil bis es die erste Mission gab, war immer noch die Idee, dass die Venus zwar ein bisschen wärmer auf der Oberfläche ist, 20, 30, 40 Grad, aber doch irgendwo erdähnlich. Und dann ist halt die erste Mariner-Mission vorbeigeflogen und hat halt Temperaturen in der tiefen Atmosphäre von 500 Grad gemessen. Das deckte sich mit dem, dass man vor schon von der Erde aus das erste Mal das gemessen hatte. Aber die erdgebundenen Messungen, da hatten viele noch gesagt, da muss irgendwas in der Methode falsch sein. Das kann gar nicht sein, dass sie so heiß ist. Und dann flog halt die Mariner-Mission vorbei und hat die gleichen Daten gemessen. Und das war das erste Mal wirklich eine Planetenmission, die ein Bild von einem Planeten fundamental geändert hat.
Mariner-Mission, da gab es ja eine ganze Reihe, ich glaube insgesamt zehn verschiedene Missionen.
Die dreier Mission, die dann weitergeflogen ist zum Merkur.
Genau. Und da waren dann alle erstmal ein bisschen geschockt. Wann war Mariner 3? Das war 1964.
Das heißt, Mariner 3, 74.
Wo gucke ich denn? Jetzt sollte ich mal nach, genau, Mariner 10, Venus und dann Merkur. 74, okay. Und da war dann auf einmal, könnte man erstmal glücklich sein, dass die Messungen von der Erde doch nicht so ungenau waren.
Genau, das heißt, die Methode von der Erde war dann bestätigt. Die Astronomen konnten sich dann bestätigt fühlen, dass ihre Messungen richtig sind. Aber durch das Bild der Venus war damit komplett auf den Kopf gestellt, weil damit war halt der subtropische Planet endgültig Geschichte.
Kein Urlaubsplanet in der Welt.
Kein Urlaubsplanet, keine Amazonen, keine großen tropischen Wälder und Ozeane.
Sondern was hat Mariner 10 dann für ein Bild geliefert, abgesehen von der Temperatur?
Mariner 10 hat im Prinzip nur gezeigt, dass der komplette Venus unter einer Wolkendecke versteckt ist. Das heißt, die Bilder sind langweilig. Wenn man die Mariner 10-Bilder anschaut, dann sieht man einfach nur eine graue oder braune Scheibe.
War das noch Schwarz-Weiß-Fotos?
Ja, das waren diese Vidikon-4-Farbfilter-Aufnahmen. Und eben gezeigt, dass die Temperatur in der Tiefe extrem hoch ist. Also die 400-500°C-Oberflächentemperatur, die man eben nicht erwartet hatte. Und die auch überall gleich war? Die 110-Daten waren überall gleich. Heute weiß man, dass die Temperatur fast auf der ganzen Oberfläche identisch ist. Die Variationen sind mit der Höhe. Auf den Bergen ist es kälter, in den Tälern ist es tiefer. Ansonsten Tag, Nacht, Nord- und Südpol ist alles die gleiche Temperatur.
Warum hat man damit nichts gerechnet?
Weil man von einem maßähnlichen oder erdähnlichen Planeten ausgegangen ist. Man wusste, es muss Atmosphäre geben. Das kann man sehen, wenn die Sonne hinter dem Venus vorbeigeht, dann sieht man, dass die nicht scharf abgeschnitten wird, sondern ein bisschen undeutlich wird, bevor sie verschwindet. Auch wenn die Wiederkop ein bisschen undeutlich ist, man wusste, da ist Atmosphäre. Aber man ging davon aus, dass die Atmosphäre etwas erdähnliches ist. Und wenn man dann einfach guckt, wie viel näher ist die Venus an der Sonne dran, dann kommt man eben nur drauf, dass es 20-30 Grad mehr sein müssen im Schnitt als bei uns.
Das war die eigentliche Fehlannahme, dass man gesagt hat, wenn Atmosphäre, dann so wie bei uns.
Richtig, genau. Oder zumindest nicht sehr viel anders als bei uns. Aber dass die Atmosphäre völlig anders ist, damit hat man halt nicht gerechnet.
Und ist man dann dem Planeten weiter zur Leibe gerückt, um dann das Bild zu vervollständigen?
Es gab dann eine ganze Reihe von Missionen, gerade von der Serviet Union. Landemissionen, aber auch Missionen im Orbit, die dann halt Stückchenweise das Bild der Venus komplettiert haben.
Die Landemissionen waren aber jetzt nicht so mega erfolgreich.
Im Nachhinein betrachtet schon.
Also sie haben nicht lange...
Okay, die waren extrem... Kurzlebig wollte ich sagen. Das Problem ist, es war halt ein klassisch russischer Ingenieursansatz. Man baut erst mal was und probiert es aus. Und wenn es nicht funktioniert, baut man es größer und stärker und probiert das aus. Venus 7 war dann halt die erste Mission, die stark genug war, um tatsächlich bis zur Oberfläche runterzukommen. Die hat ein paar Minuten überlebt. Dann hat man es noch stärker, noch größer gebaut.
Vorher gab es schon kleinere, die sind dann...
Aus verschiedenen Gründen ausgefallen. Zum Teil auf dem Weg, zum Teil in der Atmosphäre ausgefallen. Während der 7 war die erste, die es bis zur Oberfläche geschafft hat. Dann gab es einige Nachfolgemissionen. Ich glaube, die längste hat eine Stunde ausgehalten auf der Oberfläche. Was aber bei einem Druck von 90 bar und 500 Grad Celsius Temperatur schon eine beeindruckende Leistung ist.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt wusste man zumindest schon, auf was man sich da einlässt.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte man die ersten Ideen, auf was man sich einlässt. Und mit jeder Mission hat man mehr gelernt dazu.
Aber wenn man so Temperatur weiß und auch die drücke kannte, war das etwas, was man...
Zum Teil. Als Radiosophiebeobachtung hatte man eine Idee, aber nicht wirklich im Detail, wie hoch es wirklich geht. Da hat man im Prinzip gelernt mit jeder Mission, die Tiefe in der Atmosphäre eindrang, hat man mehr gelernt darüber, wie der Druck mit der Tiefe ansteigt.
Okay, aber man musste dann sozusagen immer nachliefern.
Die nächste hat man dann halt noch ein bisschen stabiler und noch ein bisschen größer gebaut, bis es dann eben gereicht hat.
Das Maximum war dann die sieben und die hat eine Minute durchgehalten.
Die hat ein paar Minuten durchgehalten.
Und dann war auch Funkstille.
Dann war auch wieder Funkstille recht, genau. Aber immerhin, die ist auf den Boden angekommen. Das ist schon eine beeindruckende Leistung gewesen. Es waren auch die ersten Landemissionen. Das war vor Viking-Missionen zum Beispiel. Dass man auf Venus erfolgreich gelandet ist und Bilder geliefert hat, bevor man es auf Mars geschafft hat, das ist schon eine beeindruckende Leistung gewesen.
Ja, das heißt, eine Weile stand Venus vor allem im sowjetischen, russischen Interesse.
Richtig, genau. Und die waren auch sehr erfolgreich da. Die haben dann Radar-Missionen geflogen, die das erste Mal die Ohrfläche kratiert haben. Eine lange Zeit war Venus die Domäne der Sowjetunion.
Warum haben sich die Amerikaner da nicht so darum gekümmert?
Die hatten sich auf dem Mars stark spezialisiert. Und dann gab es im Prinzip zwei Mal...
War das sowieso so ein Herr?
Die Sowjetunion hatte ja auch einige Mars-Missionen, die aber nicht so wirklich erfolgreich waren.
Sollte irgendwie nicht sein, so Mars und...
Mars und Sowjetunion war nicht so... Venus und Sowjetunion war eine Erfolgsgeschichte. Das ist erstaunlich, aber es ist tatsächlich so. Die Amerikaner sind relativ spät eingestiegen, damit Pioneer Venus auch eine Radar-Mission, die dann aber auch... Kleines Radar, aber hauptsächlich Atmosphär-Mission. Ja. Auch mit, die dann auch Proben abgeworfen hat, die zwar nicht bis zur Oberfläche gekommen sind, aber zumindestens die Atmosphäre stärker vermessen konnten. Dann gab es die Vega-Mission, die Ballons abgesetzt haben, der Sowjetunion wieder, wo halt ein Ballon durch die Atmosphäre geflogen ist für eine Weile. Und dann gab es die große Magellarmission der Amerikaner, die halt mit einem relativ guten Radar die komplette Oberfläche kartiert hat. Das ist zum größten Teil das, was wir immer noch heute verwenden als Karten der Venus, kommt alle von der Magellarmission, die in den 90er Jahren geflogen ist.
Aber das wird jetzt sukzessive wahrscheinlich ergänzt oder vielleicht auch ersetzt durch die Daten von Venus Express?
Venus Express hat keinen Radar an Bord. Für die Radardaten müssen wir weiter auf Magellarmission zurückgreifen und die russischen Veneradaten, die älteren, da gibt es nichts Neues. Was wir gemacht haben mit Venus Express, ist das erste Mal, im Infraroten die Oberfläche uns anzuschauen, was es vorher noch nie gegeben hat. Das war halt für uns das große Neue. Damit ergänzen wir jetzt die Radardaten, indem wir sagen, wir haben auch Infrarotdaten der Oberfläche.
Okay, also es war sozusagen auch eine der Argumentationen, dass man sagt, wir machen da jetzt kein Radar drauf, weil Radar gibt es zumindest schon in einer bestimmten Qualität?
Es gab in dem ersten Entwurf für Venus Express war auch ein Radar dabei. Das ist dann aber im Laufe der Venus Express Entwicklung dann irgendwann runtergeflogen. Also es gab ursprünglich mal ein Radar mit an Bord.
Das ist aus Kostengründen oder weil man...
Also das sind übliche Kostengründe.
Wenn es an Wissenschaftlern geht, kann man da gar nicht genug drauf haben.
Richtig, genau. Aber Venus Express war ja im Prinzip eine sehr schnelle Mission, die man gebaut hat auf der Basis für Mars Express. Also man hat den Mars Express Satelliten genommen und hat Instrumente draufgesetzt, die es schon gab.
Ja, die schnellste Mission ever.
Richtig, genau.
Drei Jahre von Start bis Start.
Genau, vom Start der Entwicklung bis zum Start des Satelliten. Das heißt, es ging nur dadurch, dass man Instrumente genommen hat, die man schon hatte, die für andere Missionen gebaut waren. Die Ersatzmodelle hat man eben draufgebaut. Der Satellit war das, war der Mars Express Satellit. Man muss ihn nur anpassen. Das hat die Entwicklung so schnell gemacht. Hat natürlich auch den Nachteil, dass kaum einst der Instrumente auf Venus Express wirklich für die Venus optimiert ist. Sondern sie sind alle für etwas anderes optimiert und man macht halt das Beste draus.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist da auch ein nennenswerter wissenschaftlicher Gewinn zu erwarten.
Eine ganze Menge, ja. Also Venus Express hat das Bild der Venus deutlich und nochmal deutlich gewandelt. Und es ist halt nach fast 20 Jahren die erste Venus-Mission wieder gewesen. Über lange Zeit war bei der Venus absolute Funkstelle. Nach dem Ende von Magellan gab es nichts mehr. Und in gewisser Weise, das sieht man halt jetzt, wenn man sich umschaut in Amerika, auch in Japan, war es eben auch der Anreiz für die dann wieder zu sagen, wenn das die Europäer können, dann müssen wir auch noch mal wieder was machen.
Die Venus Express-Mission wurde dann auch hier mit entwickelt?
Ja, genau. Wir haben einen Teil Instrumente mitgebaut. Keine kompletten Instrumente, aber wir haben einen Teil der Kamera auf Venus Express ist hier mitgebaut worden. Ein Teil der Elektronik von Einzel-Spektrometer ist hier mitgebaut worden. Wir haben eine ganze Menge an der Hardware-Entwicklung hier im Haus mitgearbeitet.
Was ist denn jetzt das Bild, was dann letztlich verschärft und verfeinert durch Venus Express sich letztlich der Wissenschaft derzeit so darstellt? Was hat man jetzt für eine Erkenntnislage über dem Planeten? Wo kommt der her? Wer hat den geliefert?
Das ist eine der großen Fragen, die auch nach Venus Express immer noch offen sind. Wenn dir das Bild vereinfacht, ist es immer so schön die höllische Schwester der Erde. Weil die Venus ist fast die gleiche Größe wie die Erde. Es ist ein bisschen näher dran als die Erde an der Sonne, aber auch nicht so wesentlich näher dran. Das heißt, eigentlich sollte man erwarten, wenn man so klassische Entstehungsmodelle für Planeten sich betrachtet und das Sonnensystem, dass die aus fast dem gleichen Material entstanden sind. Von daher kamen auch die Ideen, dass die gleich sein sollten.
Ist denn die Venus, befindet die sich so in der eigentlichen Definition der habitablen Zone?
Nee, ist außen. Es ist zu nah dran an der Sonne. Nicht viel, aber doch ein bisschen. Ja, mittlere Temperatur, 30, 40 Grad höher, wäre halt schon kritisch für die.
Ja, das heißt, wäre die Venus nur so ein Stückchen weiter raus? Ein Stückchen in die Dimensionen?
Genau, dann wäre sie...
Dann hätten wir theoretisch sogar die Chance gehabt, von zwei bewohnbaren Planeten in einem Sonnensystem. Schade eigentlich, ne?
Genau, richtig. Und stattdessen haben wir einen Planeten, der 500 Grad heiße Oberfläche hat, der 90 bar Atmosphärendruck hat, der von Schwefelsäure, Wolken umgeben ist, eine Atmosphäre oder eine Wolkendecke, die undurchdringlich ist für das normale Auge. Also weit, weit davon entfernt, auch nur andernfalls irgendwo bewohnbar zu sein.
Zumindest für Lebensformen, wie wir sie uns derzeit so vorstellen.
Richtig. Selbst für Extremlebensformen ist die Oberfläche zu extrem. Es gab so Ideen, dass in den oberen Atmosphären Schichten Leben sein könnte. Zumindest lebensfreundliche Bedingungen. Aber alles, was nur nah an der Oberfläche ist, ist außerhalb jeden Bereich, was man sich im Moment für Leben vorstellen kann.
Aber im Prinzip ist die Theorie, dass die Venus sich genauso wie die Erde einfach aus den Staubscheiben um die Sonne herausgebildet hat, sich dann ihre Bahnen quasi freigeräumt hat, wie die Erde auch. Und da einfach den Status Planet sich auch hart erarbeitet hat.
Richtig, genau.
Und dann, also jetzt, ich weiß nicht, als ich neulich hier war und über Merkur gesprochen habe, dann gab es ja noch so die Theorie, na ja, es wird auch darüber nachgedacht, ob es nicht vielleicht sein kann, dass der Merkur mal irgendwie extern eingeschossen wurde und dann nur eingefangen wurde von der Sonne. Solche Mutmaßungen gibt es jetzt über die Venus nicht.
Nee, aber nicht wirklich. Also die Venus, das ist ja genau der Punkt, an sich sollte sich ähnlich entwickelt haben wie die Erde. Und im Prinzip gleicher Frage. Die Frage ist dann halt, wann die Venus abgezweigt ist. Also wann die Entwicklung der Venus sich anders entwickelt hat als die Erde. Oder ob die Erde abgezweigt ist. Eine von den beiden hat sich halt anders entwickelt.
Aber über einen gewissen Zeitraum waren sie sich wahrscheinlich recht ähnlich.
Waren sie sich vermutlich recht ähnlich, genau. Und die Frage ist dann halt, haben wir bei der Erde Glück gehabt, dass sie halt irgendwo zufälligerweise eine Abzweigung genommen hat bei der Entwicklung, die uns hervorgebracht hat. Oder zumindest einen Planeten, der uns tragen kann. Und ist die Venus ein Normalfall? Oder hat die Venus irgendwann die Abzweigung genommen? Und die Erde ist ein Normalfall. Was eben die Frage ist, wenn man jetzt, wie wir wissen, eben viele Exoplanetensysteme hat, ist halt die Frage, was ist der Normalfall in der habitablen Zone Venus oder Erde?
Ja, als wir hier über den Mond gesprochen haben, Ausgabe 39, war ja auch eine sehr interessante Erkenntnis, dass der Mond, nach der vorherrschenden Meinung, durch eine Kollision mit einem Proto-Planeten auf derselben Umlaufbahn der Erde, der sich in einem dieser Lagrange-Punkte vielleicht gebildet hat, entstanden ist. Und dass ja auch der Mond ganz aktiv mitgestaltet, was für uns Realität ist. Die geneigte Bahn zur Sonne und damit eben auch Jahreszeiten. Das sind ja auch alles Dinge, die erhebliche Auswirkungen haben auf Atmosphäre. Letztlich ist die Atmosphäre der wesentliche Unterschied zwischen Erde und den anderen Planeten. Vielleicht hat ja der Venus auch nur so einen Einschlag und ein Mond gefehlt. Aber Mond gibt es nicht.
Mond gibt es nicht, richtig. Einen Einschlag könnte es gegeben haben, weil eine der seltsamen Dinge bei der Venus ist, dass sie sich andersrum dreht als alle anderen Planeten. Sie steht im Prinzip auf dem Kopf und dreht sich sehr, sehr langsam.
Steht auf dem Kopf?
Wenn man das andersrum dreht, kann man eben auch betrachten, dass sie auf dem Kopf steht.
Weil eigentlich so aus der Entstehungsgeschichte heraus...
Sie müsste sich genauso drehen wie alle anderen Planeten. Die Drehmomente sagen eigentlich, Venus sollte sich genauso drehen wie Merkur, Erde, Mars.
Und hat es vielleicht auch mal eine Weile getan.
Und hat es vielleicht auch mal eine Weile getan. Es gibt halt die Idee, dass es irgendwann mal einen Einschlag gegeben hat, der eben die Rotationsaktivität auf den Kopf gestellt hat. Im Prinzip den Planeten umgekippt hat.
Das heißt nicht sozusagen in die andere Richtung gedreht, sondern einfach gekippt?
Nein, sondern darum sage ich, genau richtig gekippt. Aber es hat sich eben keinen Mond dergleichen gebildet, was dann vielleicht tatsächlich geholfen hätte. Das ist einer der Fragen. Es scheint hier viele Einschläge gegeben zu haben. Wir wissen, wir kennen die ganzen Krater. Es gibt die Idee, dass Merkur einen großen Einschlag gegeben hat. Auf der Erde hat es eingegeben, sonst hätte man den Mond nicht. Wir sehen auf dem Mars viele riesige Einschlagbecken. Insofern, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es einen großen Einschlag gegeben hat, irgendwann in der Frühgeschichte, ist relativ groß.
Ja, weil alle anderen haben auch was abgekriegt.
Richtig, genau.
Man sieht auch diese Krater, das hat man dann wahrscheinlich mit dem Radar gemessen.
Das ist eine der spannenden Sachen. Wenn man sich die Venus-Oberfläche anschaut, sieht man ganz wenig Krater. Das war eine der großen Überraschungen, als man die Radardaten ausgewertet hat. Man benutzt Krater typischerweise im Sonnensystem, um Alter zu bestimmen. Man zählt einfach, wie viele Krater von einer bestimmten Größe sind da. Je mehr, umso älter. Bei der Venus gibt es erst mal ein Problem, weil die Einschlagkörper groß genug sind, um durch die Atmosphäre durchzukommen. Die ist einfach so dick, dass alles, was kleine Einschlagkörper sind, die verglühen einfach die Atmosphäre.
So wie bei uns ja auch mit Meteoriten, bloß da kommen noch ganz andere Dinge zum Tragen.
Richtig, genau. Bei der Venus sind Meteoriten viel größer als bei uns.
Was könnte die so schlucken? Was bei uns hier schon der Weltuntergang ist?
Nicht ganz, aber schon in der Größenordnung. Einige hundert Meter kommen definitiv nicht auf der Oberfläche mehr an. Aber ein paar Kilometer würden da auch schon... Es gibt einige Krater, aber die sind dann schon richtig groß. Der Punkt ist aber, selbst wenn man das mit einberechnet, dass die nicht ankommen, dann gibt es immer noch viel zu wenig Krater auf der Oberfläche der Venus. Und woraus man schlussfolgert, dass das, was wir im Moment als Oberfläche sehen, eine relativ junge Oberfläche ist. Da kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten, wie jung irgendwas zwischen 500 Millionen und einer Milliarde Jahre ist. Was im Vergleich zum Mars und zum Merkur nichts ist. Oder auch zum Mond.
Was heißt jung? Also, dass da noch so viel Vulkanismus, so viele flüssige Kerne da ist wie bei der Erde?
Das ist einer der ganz großen Streitpunkte, den es bei der Venus gibt. Man kann einfach aus den Kratern sehen, dass die Oberfläche maximal eine Milliarde Jahre alt ist. Älter kann sie nicht sein, sonst müssten mehr Krater da sein. Jetzt gibt es im Prinzip zwei Lager. Das eine Lager sagt, vor einer Milliarde Jahre gab es die große Katastrophe auf der Venus. Alle Vulkanen sind zur gleichen Zeit ausgebrochen. Die ganze Oberfläche ist auf einen Schlag neu gebildet worden. Was wir heute sehen, ist die Oberfläche, die zu dieser großen Katastrophe gebildet worden ist. Das andere Lager sagt, so eine große Katastrophe können wir uns nicht vorstellen. Aber wenn wir uns vorstellen, dass es kontinuierlich Vulkanismus gibt, der frische Krater immer wieder ausschlöscht und immer wieder überdeckt, dann würde man das Gleiche sehen. Wenn man sich die Verteilung von Kratern anschaut, die ist mehr oder weniger zufällig auf der Oberfläche. Es gibt kein wirkliches Verteilungsmuster da. Beide Lager können Argumente anführen, warum ihr Modell richtig ist. Es ist sehr schwer, zwischen den beiden einen Moment zu unterscheiden. Ist die Venus immer noch aktiv bis heute? Würde es heißen? Oder gab es vor 1 Milliarde Jahren die große Katastrophe? Dann die Frage, ist das eine Sache, die immer wieder passiert? Oder haben wir zufälligerweise gerade die eine große Katastrophe gesehen, die alles neu geformt hat?
Was muss man sich darunter vorstellen? Die große Katastrophe, also so ein Einschlag?
Nee, in dem Fall wäre es tatsächlich ein Ereignis, wo im Prinzip alle Vulkane auf der Venus in der kurzen Zeit gleichzeitig ausbrechen und wirklich die ganze Oberfläche neu geformt worden ist. Die Frage ist ja, bei der Erde, die Planeten produzieren in ihrem Inneren Wärme. Sie haben radioaktive Elemente in den Planetenkernen. Die Planeten produzieren Wärme, die wissen, wie sie irgendwie loswerden. Bei der Erde passiert das hauptsächlich durch Platten-Dectonik und durch Kleinvulkanismus, Subduktion. Bei Planeten, die keine Platten-Dectonik haben, bei der Venus sehen wir das nicht, ist eine Möglichkeit, die Wärme loszuwerden durch Vulkanismus. Es gibt die Idee, dass im Prinzip, da der große Deckel drauf war, dann haben wir einen Dampfdruck-Topf. Der wird immer heißer und irgendwann ist an dem Punkt erreicht, wo es so heiß wird, dass das Ganze, die Wärme, loswerden muss. Dann gibt es eine große Katastrophe, wo in einem relativ kurzen Zeitraum, das ist nicht ein Tag oder...
Also die Milch schäumt über.
Genau, die Milch schäumt über. Genau. Und dann hat sich in kürzester Zeit die ganze Oberfläche neu gebildet. Und das sehen wir halt jetzt. Das Gegenmodell ist eben zu sagen, das kann so nicht sein, sondern... Wir machen kontinuierlich, werden hier, da, dort immer mal wieder vulkanaktiv, die dann halt eben die Wärme nach außen...
Hast du da einen der beiden Lager irgendwie an?
Wir stehen im Moment ziemlich dazwischen.
Kann beides sein.
Kann beides sein, ja. Und ich denke auch im Endeffekt, was wahrscheinlich der Fall sein wird, dass es tatsächlich einfach ein Zwischenmodell ist. Weil das es schon Perioden gegeben hat, wo es massiv mehr Vulkanismus hat. Genau. Nicht auf einer Skala, dass wirklich das ganze Planet neu gebildet worden ist, aber schon auf einer Skala, wo halt große Gebiete neu gebildet worden sind. Aber ich bin auch immer noch davon überzeugt, dass wir Vulkanismus bis heute haben. Das haben wir eine Sache, die wir versucht haben mit Venus Express zu schauen, ob wir eine Chance haben, Vulkanismus zu sehen, aktiv. Das haben wir nicht geschafft, aber auf der anderen Seite waren wir auch nicht unbedingt ideal darauf vorbereitet.
Verstehe. Das heißt, wenn wir nochmal davon ausgehen, Erde und Venus sind sich sehr ähnlich. Das gilt jetzt, was den inneren Aufbau betrifft, mit ziemlicher Sicherheit. Also auch da ein fetter Eisenkern, entsprechende Hitze, Magma etc. Und in irgendeiner Form muss das nach außen getragen werden, wo es bei der Erde eben diese Tektonik, das Verschieben der Planeten und das Zusammenspiel mit den Ozeanen etc. Das kühlt die Erde auf so einen permanenten Weg ab. Ab und zu wird es doch mal zu heiß. Dann haben wir mal wieder einen Vulkatausbruch. Aber eigentlich ist das ja Pipifax im Vergleich zu dem gesamten Umfeld. Aber bei der Venus kann man sicher sagen, dass es diese Tektonik in dem Sinne nicht gibt.
Wir haben keine Anzeichen dafür gefunden. Das war mal so eine frühe Idee, dass es da auch sowas Kontinentähnliches gegeben haben könnte. Aber man sieht keine wirklich Anzeichen dafür.
Aber man kann ja auch gar nicht so gut gucken.
Auf der Skala kann man schon gucken. Man sieht ein paar Hochländer auf der Venus. Aber die sind wesentlich kleiner als Kontinenten auf der Erde. Und wir haben bis jetzt zumindest keine wirklichen Anzeichen von Platentektonik gefunden. Es gibt die Idee, und da würde ich durchaus mitgehen, dass es Platentektonik in kleinen Gebieten gegeben hat. Also dass es schon kleine Gebiete gegeben hat, wo sowas ähnliches wie Platentektonik mal passiert ist für eine Zeit, aber definitiv nicht auf der Skala des ganzen Planeten.
Das heißt, man kann von der Oberfläche schon so weitgehend von einer erstarrten Masse ausgehen, auch wenn sie vielleicht anders zusammengesetzt ist.
So sieht es zumindest auf jeden Fall im Moment aus. Natürlich mit massiven Vulkanismus. Und zwar Vulkanismus wirklich auf einer Skala, die wir uns auf der Erde kaum vorstellen können. Wir haben Lava-Flüße auf der Venus, die im Vergleich Deutschland in Flensburg ist der Vulkan ausgebrochen, und der Lava-Fluss geht bis gar im Spattenkirchen und sogar bis an die Alpen ran. Das ist nicht ungewöhnlich für die Venus. Das heißt, das ist schon eine völlig andere Skala, als das, was wir uns hier auf der Erde als Vulkanausbruch vorstellen können.
Frächige Lava-Autobahnen. Oha. Das heißt, diese Länder, die die Russen da auf die Oberfläche geschickt haben, die haben auch keine geringe Wahrscheinlichkeit gehabt, dass sie so direkt in der Lava gelandet sind?
Das ist ja die Frage, ob es noch aktive Vulkane heute gibt. Bis jetzt haben wir keine Anzeichen dafür gefunden, dass es noch aktive Vulkane gibt. Wir haben danach gesucht mit Venus Express. Und zwar, was wir versucht haben, ist zu schauen, ob man im Prinzip die Wärmesignatur von einem Vulkan sieht. Der ist ja heißer, sogar noch heißer als die normale Oberfläche. Das heißt, wenn wir mit dem Faroten schauen, wenn wir Glück gehabt hätten, hätte man irgendwo einen heißen Punkt gesehen, der an Vulkanen gesprochen hätte. Das haben wir während der Venus-Express-Mission probiert. Wir haben ein paar Punkte gesehen, aber keiner, der wirklich als Vulkan identifizierbar war. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man sich das anschaut, im Vergleich auch mit der Erde, wenn man zufälligerweise hier mal da auf der Erde hinschaut, ist die Chance, gerade einen Vulkan zu sehen, auch nicht gerade groß. Wir haben uns das mal dann einfach nach der Statistik angeschaut und haben dann festgestellt, dass unsere Chance wirklich zufälligerweise einen Vulkan zu treffen, relativ klein war. Es hinkt damit zusammen, auf welcher Bahn Venus Express war und wie oft wir angeschaltet waren, um was zu schauen. Man müsste dann wirklich einen Satelliten schicken, der ganz gezielt nach Vulkanismus über lange Zeit sucht, um sagen zu können, ja oder nein.
Und der den vielleicht die Venus auch in einem konstanten Abstand umkreist.
Richtig, genau.
Venus Express hat ja so eine stark elliptische Bahn.
Richtig, genau. Das hat uns nicht gerade geholfen. Das heißt, da müsste man wirklich im Prinzip so einen Vulkan-Monitor-Satelliten schicken, der nur danach sucht.
So wie die Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten hier auch, die einfach in fester Höhe kreisen.
Richtig. Insofern, dass wir nichts gesehen haben, heißt nicht, dass nichts da war, sondern wir hatten einfach nur kein Glück in der Zeit. Es wäre ein großes Glück gewesen, wenn wir einen gesehen hätten.
Aber sollte es mal eine zukünftige Mission geben, die nach diesem Prinzip funktioniert, dann wäre das zumindest eine der Sachen, auf die man genauer hinschauen würde, um ein vollständiges Bild zu bekommen. Dann könnte es durchaus sein, dass man welche entdeckt.
Richtig, genau. Das ist auch eine der Sachen, wir haben ja auch davon gelernt, was wir bei Venus Express gemacht haben. Wir denken auch selber darüber nach, was wäre aus unserer Sicht eine Mission, die man schicken könnte, um genau so etwas zu machen. Was wäre ein Instrument, das man schicken könnte, um genau nach Vulkanen suchen zu können?
Das heißt, der Kern ist ähnlich wie die Erde, die Oberfläche ist es schon nicht mehr. Nicht nur wegen der Temperatur, sondern weil wahrscheinlich alles erstarrt ist, es könnte Vulkane geben, vielleicht auch nicht, weiß man nicht, kriegt man vielleicht irgendwann noch mal raus. Also an sich ist das schon mal alles relativ öde da. Dazu kommt jetzt aber auch noch diese spezielle Atmosphäre, die ganz anders ist als unsere Atmosphäre, die vor allem auch mega dicht ist und ätzend und was nicht alles. Also was weiß man darüber?
Sie besteht zu 95% aus CO2, das Kohlendioxid, hat einen Druck von 90 bar an der Oberfläche, ist also wesentlich dichter als die Erdatmosphäre und einen extrem geringen Anteil an Wasser. Und das Ganze dann verbunden mit einer sehr dichten Wolkenschicht, die vermutlich aus Schwefelsäure-artigen Partikeln besteht. Also wirklich eine völlig andere Zusammensetzung als das, was wir von der Erdatmosphäre kennen. Interessanterweise, wenn man schaut zum Mars, 95 Prozent CO2 ist fast identisch mit der Marsatmosphäre. Viel dünner die Marsatmosphäre, aber Zusammensetzung in den Verhältnissen der Gasen zwischen Mars und Venus ist relativ ähnlich. Und auch da wieder der Punkt, wahrscheinlich haben wir eben mit vielen Dingen auf der Erde Glück gehabt, dass unsere Atmosphäre eben anders aufgebaut ist. Zum Beispiel das Wasser, was eben CO2 binden kann, wo Kalkgestein entsteht, was wir auf der Venus-Oberfläche zumindest zum Momentwissen nicht haben.
Das heißt, es gibt Wasser, aber es gibt nicht viel Wasser?
Es gibt einen ganz geringen Anteil von Wasser in der Atmosphäre, im Promillbereich, wenn überhaupt. Oberfläche gibt es gar nichts. Die Wolken haben kein Wasser, es ist viel zu heiß dafür. Das ist eine der großen Fragen, wo das Wasser der Venus geblieben ist. Wenn man erstmal davon ausgeht, dass sich die Venus ähnlich gebildet hat wie die Erde, dann sollte sie mit einem ähnlichen Wasseranteil gestartet sein als die Erde. Die Frage ist dann, wo ist das Wasser heute? Es gibt verschiedene Modelle dafür. Es gibt Modelle, die sagen, dass die Venus durchaus in frühen Phasen mal Wasser hatte, vielleicht sogar Wasser auf der Oberfläche. Und das dann im Laufe der Zeit verloren gegangen ist. Durch verschiedene Prozesse. Es kann irgendwo in der Tiefe der Venus Wasser gebunden sein, was wir heute nicht sehen. Und man sieht eben, eine der Modelle, die es gibt und die eben ganz spannend sind, ist, die sagen, dass es durchaus mal Wasser auf der Oberfläche gegeben hat. In gewisser Weise Ozeane, nicht groß, aber schon vorhanden. Und dass dann aber das Wasser verdampft ist, Wolken gebildet hat. Und im Prinzip das ein Start für einen Treibhaus-Effekt war. Weil Wasserdampf ist ein relativ effektives Treibhausgas. Und das heißt, man kann im Prinzip mit den Wasserdampfwolken könnte man dann diesen Treibhaus-Effekt gestartet haben, der sich dann immer weiter verstärkt hat, bis zu dem, was wir eben heute sehen. Das heißt also im Prinzip, dass dieser Effekt selber dann den Wasserdampf, das Wasser von der Venus verdampft hat. Und wenn man es in die höhere Präferien bringt, dann verliert der Planet eben durch den Sonnenwind das Wasser effektiv.
Das heißt, die Venus ist im Prinzip so, die finstere Voraussicht für das, was auch mal mit der Erdnuss-Atmosphäre passieren könnte, wenn man es hier irgendwann mal übertreibt.
Das ist einer der Hintergründe, warum man sich die Venus-Atmosphäre so im Detail anschaut, weil das eben tatsächlich die Frage ist, ist das der natürliche Zustand? Wenn der Treibhaus-Effekt einfach immer weiter geht, kommt man irgendwann zu einem Punkt, wo er unumkehrbar wird und dann eben sich immer weiter verstärkt. Dann landet man irgendwann bei einer Venus-Bedingung. Oder ist es ein spezieller Fall, dass aus welchen Gründen noch immer dieser Treibhaus-Effekt auf der Venus wesentlich stärker ist als bei uns? Aber es spricht eben viel dafür, dass es tatsächlich, wenn man einen gewissen Punkt überschreitet beim Treibhaus-Effekt, dass es dann immer weitergeht.
Also der Point of No Return.
Richtig, genau. Dann landet man irgendwann eben bei Bedingungen, wie wir sie jetzt auf der Venus haben.
Das ist ja nicht unbedingt so das Sommerwetter, was man sich hier wünschen würde.
Nicht wirklich, nee.
Die Venus ist ja sehr, weiß nicht, von der Farbgebung her sehr von diesem Schwiefel dominiert. Muss man sich das so vorstellen? Ich hab jetzt so gerade keine Bilder im Kopf geltlich.
Ja, also die Bilder, die man normalerweise sieht, aber die sind natürlich nachgefärbt dann. Es waren ja Schwarz-Weiß-Bilder, die die russischen Missionen gemacht haben. Aber es wird vermutlich so eine gelbliche Tönung sein. Das ist einer der interessanten Anekdoten bei den Venus-Missionen, die gelandet sind. Die hatten Keramikscheiben dabei, mit denen man die Farben kalibrieren wollte. Die hatten eine bekannte Farbe. Die Kamera hat auf die Oberfläche geschaut und auf die Scheiben. Dann hätte man anhand der Scheiben die Farbe bestimmen können. Das Problem ist aber, dass die Venus-Atmosphäre die Scheiben zersetzt hat. Das heißt, man weiß nicht genau, welche Farbe die im Endeffekt hatten. Die Farbbilder, die man heute sieht, sind alle so gut angepasst, wie man sich das vorstellen kann.
Bei welcher Mission war das mit den Pyramiden?
Die Venere-Missionen hatten wir.
Wie macht das Venus Express?
Venus Express ist ja nicht auf der Oberfläche. Der Punkt war da, dass die auf der Oberfläche gelandet sind.
Also dann sozusagen in der, direkt auf dem Planeten noch die Farbe zu messen. Aber so Außenbilder macht die Venus Express ja auch.
Richtig, genau. Das ist so eine gelblich-bräunliche Wolkendecke. Nicht so schön.
Also man sieht natürlich ganz nett aus und reflektiert auch immer noch genug Licht.
Richtig, genau. Als Morgenstern zu dienen. Auf der Oberfläche ist es halt so ein diesiger Tag in Berlin. Also es ist nicht wirklich dunkel. Man trost sehr der dichten Wolken. Es koppelt noch genug Licht durch. Aber man sieht halt die Sonne nicht. Es ist halt diffuses Licht, was von allen Seiten kommt. Und es ist halt so ein...
Smog.
Ja, genau, richtig. Und dann ein sehr wolkiger Tag in Berlin. Die Russen sagen immer, es ist halt der klassisch wolkige Tag in Moskau. Als Vergleich für wie hell es denn da ist.
Aber man sieht schon noch was.
Man sieht schon was, klar. In den Kameras haben wir auch was gesehen. Und man bekommt schon noch genug Licht auf der Oberfläche.
Wie muss man sich denn so einen Tag auf der Venus vorstellen? Also wie schnell rotiert die Venus falsch rum?
234 Tage, also es ist eine sehr, sehr langsame Rotation.
234 Tage, bis die einmal um sich selbst gedreht ist?
Genau, richtig, richtig. Das ist eine sehr, sehr langsame Rotation.
Entspricht das auch der Umdrehung um die Sonne?
Nein, nicht ganz, aber es ist eine ähnliche Größenordnung.
Das heißt, ein Tag entspricht fast einem Jahr auf der Venus? Gibt es keinen richtigen Unterschied?
Es gibt eh keinen Unterschied. Klar, es ist hell und dunkel, aber ansonsten, was Temperaturen angeht auf der Oberfläche, gibt es keinen Unterschied. Nacht und Tag sind gleich heiß auf der Oberfläche.
Aber wenn jetzt die Umdrehung um die Sonne fast identisch ist mit der Rotation, bedeutet das ja, dass eigentlich wie der Mond...
Ist nicht identisch. Es ist ähnlich, aber nicht identisch. Die dauert immer noch etwas.
Aber zumindest wird eine Seite dann wirklich sehr lange beschienen und eine andere Seite wird sehr lange nicht beschienen.
Richtig, genau.
Und trotzdem ist die Temperatur aber gleichmäßig.
Weil die Dichtatmosphäre halt die Temperatur so ausgleicht, dass die Oberflächentemperatur macht keinen Unterschied mehr.
Das heißt, es wird einfach weitergeleitet wie mit dem Heiz-Element.
Richtig, genau. Wärmeleitung ist so gut, dass es da praktisch keinen Unterschied gibt.
Das heißt, wenn es dann mal dunkel ist, dann ist es auch so richtig lange dunkel.
Dann ist es auch richtig lange dunkel, genau.
Und trotzdem ist es auch noch furchtbar heiß. Das ist ja jetzt irgendwie auch nicht so der Urlaubsort der Wahl. Nicht wirklich. Was weiß man denn jetzt mittlerweile über das Magnetfeld der Venus?
Dass es keins gibt.
Richtig. Venus Express hat ja auch noch einen extra Magnetometer an Bord. Auch die vorherigen Missionen haben keins gefunden. Venus Express hat keins gefunden. Also es gibt ziemlich sicher kein Magnetfeld.
Aber ist das nicht sehr überraschend?
Der Mars hat keins, der Merko hat eins, die Erde hat eins. Magnetfelder im Sonnensystem sind immer überraschend. Es gibt kein klares Muster, nachdem der eine Planet eins hat, der andere Planet keins hat. Man würde natürlich erwarten wieder, dass sich die Venus ähnlich entwickelt hat wie die Erde. Also sprich, sollte die Venus eigentlich ein Magnetfeld haben so wie die Erde. Rotierender Kern, Dynamo-Effekt hat sie nicht. Die Frage ist eben da auch wieder, hatte sie mal eins in der frühen Phase und ist da Dynamo dann irgendwann angehalten oder hat er nie gestartet? Das ist aber eine Sache, die können wir bis jetzt zumindest nicht nachweisen. Wir wissen nur, bis zu der Genauigkeit, mit der wir messen können, es gibt keinen Magnetfeld auf der Venus. Das ist ein Teil dessen natürlich, weil das Magnetfeld der Erde schützt unsere Atmosphäre in gewisser Weise, weil sie den Sonnenwind ableitet. Bei der Venus gibt es den Schutz nicht. Das heißt, die Venus verliert nicht mehr ihre Atmosphäre. Da sind wir bei der Geschichte, dass die Venus zum Beispiel Wasser sehr effektiv verliert, weil der Sonnenwind eben tatsächlich auf die Atmosphäre auftrifft.
Der Sonnenwind trifft auf die Atmosphäre auf. Und was macht er? Also schützt die Atmosphäre den Planeten irgendwie vor diesem Sonnenwind? Oder trägt das dann irgendwie noch weiter?
Der Sonnenwind trägt im Prinzip Teileatmosphäre weg. Die äußeren Teileatmosphäre können eben dann vom Sonnenwind weggetragen werden. Das heißt, wenn zum Beispiel Wasser hoch genug in Atmosphäre kommt, wird sich durch den UV-Schrank der Sonne in Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff getrennt, geladene Teilchen, die dann sehr effektiv vom Sonnenwind mit weggetragen werden.
Das heißt, die Venus wird die ganze Zeit geschliffen in ihrer Oberfläche. Wenn da noch Wasser ist, dann wird es auch tendenziell immer weniger.
Richtig, genau.
Sodass man eigentlich davon ausgehen kann, dass das bisschen, was noch da ist, über kurz oder lang, auch noch komplett verschwinden wird?
Ja, also im Zwischen, ist ja so wenig da, dass kaum noch was weggetragen werden kann. Aber man kann natürlich zurückrechnen, dass ja einer der, wo die Ideen herkommen, dass es mal mehr Wasser gegeben hat. Wenn man einfach zurückrechnet, wie viel weggetragen wird und wie viel dann mal da gewesen sein muss, dann sieht man, dass in der frühen Phase der Venus tatsächlich mehr Wasser, genug Wasser gewesen sein kann, als dass es eben Wasser auf der Oberfläche gegeben hat.
Also so, wie wir uns das hier vorstellen. Meeren, Seen etc.
Vielleicht nicht in den gleichen Mengen, aber zumindest irgendwo in der Art und Weise.
Popfützen.
Genau.
Das ist ja alles irgendwie auch beunruhigend, wenn man sich das mal so vorstellt als Vision für unseren Planeten. Gibt es denn irgendetwas, was man daraus jetzt auch unmittelbar an Wissen gewinnen kann, was hier auch auf der Erde anwendbar wäre? Oder lernt man sozusagen aus der Beobachtung der Venus auch Dinge, die man hier für die Beobachtung unserer Atmosphäre in irgendeiner Form wieder zurückverwerten kann?
Zum Teil schon, weil die Venus eine relativ einfache Atmosphäre aufgebaut hat und ein relativ einfaches Wettersystem hat. Man kann Atmosphärenmodelle auf der Venus nutzen, die einfacher sind als auf Erde. Wenn man das Venus-System versteht, kriegt man etwas besseren Einblick darin, wie Trepphaus-Effekt funktioniert. Das kann man als Rückschluss nutzen, um damit auf der Erde Projektionen zu machen. Wie könnte der Trepphaus-Effekt aussehen in 10, 20, 30, 50 Jahren, wenn wir so weitermachen, wie wir im Moment auf dem Weg sind, wenn mehr CO2 eingetragen wird in die Atmosphäre?
Wetter heißt ja, es gibt Veränderungen in der Atmosphäre. Was ändert sich denn da noch groß? Finden da Stürme statt?
Man hat hier die Wolken. Man sieht, wenn man die Wolken anschaut, dass es relativ starke Winde gibt. Es gibt eben Zellen in der Atmosphäre, wo Material, Atmosphäre hochgetragen wird. Es gibt um die Polregionen große Wirbelstürme. Auf einer der Sachen, die Venus Express intensiv beobachtet hat, wirklich große Wirbelstürmezonen.
Insbesondere im Süden?
Im Süden hat man es am besten gesehen. Im Norden gab es auch. Im Süden hat man es das erste Mal im Detail gesehen. Im Norden hatte Pioneer Venus schon mal gesehen. Am Süden war es eine Neuentdeckung, dass es sie im Süden auch gibt. Man kann sich diese Windsysteme sehr genau anschauen. Wie ist die Zirkulation der Atmosphäre? Auf einer großen Skala, größer als die auf der Erde. Dann hat man den Effekt, dass die Venus drei Wolkenschichten hat, die relativ klar aufeinander getrennt sind in verschiedenen Höhen. Die oberste Wolkenschicht dreht sich mit einer extrem hohen Geschwindigkeit. Einige Stunden ist sie um den ganzen Planeten drum herum. Dann kann man schauen, wo die Energie dafür herkommt, dass sich die Wolken so schnell bewegen können.
Und die anderen Schichten drehen sich nicht so oft?
Je weiter man nach unten kommt, umso langsamer wird es. Auf der Oberfläche hat man noch so ein laues Lüftchen, was sich dann bewegt. Das ist ein starker Unterschied zwischen den obersten Schichten und bis man runterkommt zur Oberfläche.
diese Stürme, die man beobachtet, spielen sich im Wesentlichen in den oberen Schichten ab. Wenn man jetzt in der Lage wäre, mit chemischen Situationen und Temperatur klarzukommen, würde man zumindest nicht vom Strom weggeweht werden.
Das ist ganz harmlos.
Also wenn man erst mal da durch ist, dann ist das alles ganz easy.
Darum gibt es Ideen, dass man Ballonmissionen in die Tiefatmosphäre schickt. Die würden durch den Wind langsam um den Planeten drum herum getrieben. Die hätten damit also kein Problem mit Stürmen.
man würde einmal durch die äußere Atmosphäre durchstechen und dann dort einen Ballon auspacken und der fliegt dann ein bisschen durch die Gegend.
Wir haben ja die Vega-Missionen schon gemacht. Die hatten ja Ballons, die es eine ganze Weile gemacht haben. Das ist, wenn man in die Zukunft guckt, Ideen für Missionen zu Venus. Das ist eine Missionensidee, die immer mal wieder auftaucht. Statt auf die Oberfläche runterzugehen, in 30, 40 km, gerade unter der untersten Wolkenschicht, mit einem Ballon über längere Zeit die Oberfläche beobachten zu können.
Aber man müsste sich trotzdem immer noch mit dem ganzen Späfel aus den Händen setzen.
Richtig, es ist auch immer noch ein Relativ-Vordruck, immer noch eine Höhertemperatur, aber eben nicht mehr so extrem wie das auf der Oberfläche.
Was wäre jetzt so nach der Venus-Express-Mission das, was man eigentlich noch mal am intensivsten untersuchen müsste, wenn man jetzt eine zukünftige Mission andenkt, was ja auch getan wird, wie zum Beispiel jetzt mit dem Ballon? Was will man erstmal wissen? Was sind sozusagen die größten Fragezeichen derzeit? Was ist das, was noch am wenigsten erkundschaftet wurde von der Venus, wo man als nächstes reinpiksen möchte?
Die großen Unbekannten sind natürlich immer noch die Oberfläche. Wir haben Lande an ein paar wenigen Stellen gehabt und haben jetzt mit Venus-Express das erste Mal eine Kartierung der Oberfläche gemacht, im Verroten. Wir haben aber immer noch eine sehr rudimentäre Idee, wie die Oberfläche zusammengesetzt ist. Und dann natürlich, wenn man ins Innere geht. Planetenkern, wie ist der wirkliche Aufbau? Das geht dann eben in die ganzen Modelle rein. Die Frage, gibt es Beben auf der Venus zum Beispiel? Ist Venus aktiv, vulkanisch, tektonisch? Ich denke, was in der Zukunft verstärkt gemacht werden wird, ist tatsächlich, von der Oberfläche ins Innere reinzuschauen. Atmosphäre haben wir inzwischen ein relativ gutes Verständnis. Und Venus Express hat eine Menge neue Daten geliefert als Atmosphäre. Das heißt, jetzt ist groß unbekannt alles, was unter der Atmosphäre stattfindet.
Also nicht nur die Oberfläche, sondern auch ins Innere rein. Aber wie schaut man ins Innere rein? Durch Messung der Gravitation? Das wird ja auch gemacht.
Richtig, aber auch da gibt es eben, Margellan war die letzte Mission, die das wirklich im Detail gemacht hat. Und inzwischen haben wir wesentlich bessere Techniken, um das wesentlich genauer machen zu können. Damit könnte man ins Innere schauen. Dann ein Seismometer auf der Oberfläche.
Also die Bebenaktivität?
Bebenaktivität messen zu können. Magnetfeldmessungen tiefer, dass man zu schauen kann, ob es irgendwo lokalen Magnetfelder gibt, wie bei Mars. Dass es halt magnetisierte Regionen gibt. Dafür muss man aber sehr, sehr nahe rankommen, also sprich in die Atmosphäre reinkommen, um das machen zu können. Ein Radar für die Tiefe, im Prinzip wie das Marsisradar auf Mars Express, dass man die Struktur unter der Oberfläche untersuchen kann. Aber bis jetzt haben wir Radar eben nur gehabt auf der Oberfläche. Ein Radar, mit dem wir tatsächlich mal in die Strukturen reinschauen könnten, wäre ein Riesengewinn.
Könnte man jetzt, müsste man dazu in die Atmosphäre gehen, um so tief reinzuschauen, oder brauchst du einfach nur aktuelle Radartechnik?
Da bräuchte man aktuelle neue Radartechnik, das könnten wir auch als Umlaufbahn noch machen.
Das klingt jetzt alles nicht gerade wie so etwas, was man so ohne Weiteres in einer einzigen Mission vereinen könnte, da müsste man sich sozusagen schon ein bisschen entscheiden.
Richtig, genau. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Missionsideen, die aber alle dann immer einen speziellen Aspekt davon rausgreifen. Man kann nicht, also es ist unwahrscheinlich, dass man alles in einem großen Schlag erledigen kann. Es gab mal, wenn man eine Idee hat, was die größte Ordnung ist, es gab auf der amerikanischen Seite mal einen Vorschlag für eine große Mission, die das mehr oder weniger alles auf einen Schlag beantworten kann. Und das war eine Mission, die studiert worden ist im Vergleich zu einer Sample-Return-Mission von Mars. Also das ist sprich die gleiche Aufwand, der gleiche Kostenaufwand. Und die Idee war, wenn man keinen Mars-Sample-Return macht, was könnte man mit dem gleichen Geld machen? Und dann war halt eine Venus-Mission geplant. Aber um eben all das beantworten zu können, braucht man wirklich den Aufwand.
Also Sample-Return heißt hinfliegen, aber auch wieder was zurückfliegen lassen, um mal wirklich ein Stein...
Das wäre bei der Venus noch der Folge. Nee, nee, also das war eine Mission, die hatte einen großen Orbiter mit verschiedenen Instrumenten. Die hatte einen Lander, der lange auf der Oberfläche überleben kann.
Ich meine jetzt der Vergleich mit der Mars-Mission.
Richtig, genau, richtig.
Um mal zu erklären, was Sample-Return heißt. Richtig, genau. Soweit würde man noch nicht gehen bei der Venus. Also man wäre froh, wenn man runterkommt.
Richtig, es gibt Studien für einen Probenrückbringung von der Venus-Oberfläche, aber das Spannende dabei, wieder die Atmosphäre der Venus, eine Rakete kann nicht von der Oberfläche starten.
Weil?
Weil der Antrieb reicht einfach nicht, um gegen die Dichtatmosphäre anzukommen.
Das heißt, die Gravitation ist gar nicht das Primäre?
Nein, sondern die Dichtatmosphäre. Das heißt, die Idee für eine Probenrückbringung von Venus ist im Prinzip, dass man landet, eine Probe greift, mit einem Ballon erst mal wieder aufsteigt, und dann, wenn man hoch genug ist und die Atmosphäre dünn genug ist, dann von dem Ballon aus, den die Rakete startet, die die Probe dann aus der Atmosphäre bringt. Also das ist ferne, ferne Zukunft.
Das heißt, die Atmosphäre ist so stark, dass sie eigentlich auch alles so an den Planeten heran drückt, dass man da noch nicht mal mit der... Also was heißt, Rakete würde nicht ausreichen? Die Rakete, die man da hinschicken könnte, die würde nicht ausreichen.
Runterbringen könnte, genau, würde nicht ausreichen. Klar, man kann natürlich immer größere Raketen bauen, aber die muss man irgendwie zur Oberfläche runterbringen.
Aber wenn man schon so eine Rakete hätte, wie wir sie hier starten, dann würde das auch da gehen.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Aber sowas muss man natürlich da auch erst mal hinschicken. Es gibt ja auch eine andere Mission der Japaner, die sich der Venus annehmen will. Aber die hatte ja bestimmte Schwierigkeiten, dort hinzukommen. Also da ist konkret das Bremsmanöver schiefgegangen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man weiß, warum.
Weiß man warum? Es gibt verschiedene Ideen, ja. Das ist ja der Venus Climate Orbiter. Das war gedacht als Wettertätilit für die Venus. Der wäre halt im Prinzip genau wie Erdwettertätiliten in der Umlaufbahn in den Äquator gegangen. Der hätte halt über lange Zeit das Wetter der Venus...
Also im konstanten Abstand. Genau, richtig. Ist eigentlich schon unterwegs.
Und die ist unterwegs, genau. Die hätte eigentlich in die Umlaufbahn eintreten sollen. Es gibt verschiedene Ideen. Entweder ist das Triebwerk explodiert. Die Triebwerkdüse explodiert bei dem Manöver. Oder der Treibschiff ist nicht nachgeliefert worden. Auf jeden Fall war das Bremsmanöver nicht lang genug. Der Tätet hat angefangen zu taumeln. Als er angefangen hat zu taumeln, ist das Bremsmanöver abgebrochen worden. Der Tätet ist an der Venus vorbeigeflogen. Er ist im Moment in der Umlaufbahn um die Sonne. Er kommt in drei Jahren, 2015, 2016, wieder in die Nähe der Venus.
Aber er funkt noch und alles.
Er funkt noch, im Moment lebt alles noch an Bord. Es ist allerdings unklar, die Batterie an Bord war eigentlich nur vor zwei Jahren ausgelegt. Das ist eine große Unbekannte, wie lange die Batterien an Bord wirklich durchhalten werden. Im Moment funktionieren die Instrumente alle noch und nehmen auch Daten auf.
Aber das Ding wird auch eigene Solarpanele haben.
Ja, aber man braucht trotzdem, wenn man im Schatten des Planeten ist, die Batterien. Das heißt also, in dem Moment, wo er im Schatten ist, würde das Elite sterben.
Und die können nicht wieder aufgeladen werden?
Das ist halt wie Akkus, die haben eine gewisse Lebensdauer. Und der ursprüngliche Idee, weil die Missionslebensdauer war halt auf ein Jahr plus ein Jahr beschränkt und entsprechend sind die Batterien ausgelegt worden. Jetzt brauchen sie halt viel, viel mehr Jahre. Das viel größere Problem ist halt, dass sie kein Brems-Triebwerk mehr haben. Also man hat es ausprobiert und das Brems-Triebwerk liefert keinen Schub mehr. Wir haben letztes Jahr, nein, dieses Jahr, dieses Jahr einen kurzen Test gemacht, wo sie das Brems-Triebwerk für einige Sekunden getündet haben, um zu schauen, wie viel Schub noch da ist. Und es ist nichts, oder fast nichts. Auf jeden Fall nicht ausreichend, um um die Umlaufbahn zu kommen. Und es gibt jetzt einen ganz abenteuerlichen Plan. Wenn der funktionieren würde, wäre das genial, einfach weil es noch nie in der Art gemacht worden ist. Dass man versucht, den kompletten Treibstoff, der noch da ist, abzulassen, um den Satelliten so leicht zu machen, wie nur möglich. Und dass man dann, wenn man nah an der Venus vorbeifliegt, die Lagekorrektur-Manöver, Düsen verwendet, die funktionieren noch, haben natürlich wesentlich geringeren Schub, weil die nur dafür da sind, den Satelliten zu bewegen. Die verwendet zum Bremsen und die Schwungräder, die man normalerweise nutzt, um den Satelliten stabil zu halten. Und das man mit Schwungrädern und den Lagekontrolldüsen zusammen dann ein Bremsmanöver durchführt, das gerade eben reicht, um den Satelliten einzufangen. Das ist ein absolut verrücktes Manöver. Wenn es jemand schafft, dann ist es Juxa, weil die halt ein gutes Team haben, um sich Rettungsmanöver durchzuführen. Das heißt, wenn sie es schaffen, dann wahrscheinlich die, aber die Chancen sind relativ gering, muss man auch sehen.
Was qualifizierte dieses Rettungsteam da so besonders? Warum ist da Juxa so weit vor?
Weil sie das jetzt schon mehrfach bei anderen Missionen machen mussten. Hayabusa, die Asteroiden-Mission, die im Prinzip tot war, haben sie trotzdem irgendwie zur Erde zurückgebracht. Haben erfolgreiche Proben zurückgebracht, was wahrscheinlich die meisten anderen Länder einfach abgeschrieben hätten, als es funktioniert nicht mehr.
Nozomi, die Mars-Mission, das ist dann wahrscheinlich für die Japaner einfach so ein Ehrverlust, wenn man das verlieren würde, dass sie sich da wirklich verstehen.
Ja, richtig. Als ich das gehört hab, wie sie das jetzt versuchen wollten, hab ich gedacht, auf die Idee muss man jetzt mal kommen, dass man halt auf die Version Bremsmanöver macht.
Ist es nicht auch ein bisschen naheliegend? Das ist ja nur das Einzige, womit sie bremsen können.
Natürlich, aber...
Was macht den Erfolg so gering? Weil die Anziehungskraft der Venus eigentlich nicht wirklich ausreicht.
Man muss sehr genau das treffen. Und da ihr Haupttriebwerk nicht mehr funktioniert, können sie kaum noch Bahnänderungsmanöver machen. Sie wüssten schon genau, wo sie hinmüssten.
Und es ist nur sehr schwierig, genau diese Bahn einzunehmen. Es gibt jetzt auch keine Swing-By-Optionen mehr. Im Wesentlichen bewegt sich das Ding auf der Bahn der Venus.
Richtig, genau.
Und holt quasi die Venus von hinten ein.
Richtig, genau. Aber ich meine, ich drücke ihnen die Daumen. Das wäre toll, wenn sie es dann schaffen würden.
Aber ist die Frage, ob dann überhaupt noch genug Power da ist, um dann noch die Lagekorrektur, die erforderlich ist, um die Bahn zu halten?
Die Mission wird sicher nicht lange an der Venus-Umlaufbahn leben, aber man hätte zumindest noch mal...
Die wollen da auf jeden Fall hin.
Und es wäre die nächste Venus-Mission. Ich meine, es ist halt... Danach ist erst mal keine in Sicht.
Nichts geplant.
Zumindest nichts konkret geplant. Nichts ausgewählt. Ich meine, es gibt jede Menge Vorschläge für Venus-Missionen, aber es ist nichts ausgewählt im Moment.
Das heißt, das steht alles so auf dem... Könnte man mal vorschlagen und vielleicht wird es auch eingereicht, aber...
Es sind ja auch immer irgendwelche vorgeschlagen worden, aber eben nicht ausgewählt worden.
Ja, derzeit scheint der Mars dann doch irgendwie...
Der Mars gewinnt eigentlich fast immer bei diesen Auswahlgeschichten, ja.
Schade eigentlich, oder?
Man kann halt nicht mit dem sexy, es gibt, wir werden Leben auf der Venus finden Faktor kommen. Und der Mars hat das natürlich immer voraus, dass man immer da mit dem winken kann, dass man nach Leben oder lebenseindlichen Bedingungen dergleichen auf dem Mars sucht. Das können wir halt für die Venus nicht machen.
Ja, man ist jetzt auch so ein bisschen dran am Mars.
Ja klar, natürlich, klar.
Viel Gewinn.
Richtig.
Naja, heißt ja nicht, dass nicht auch andere spannende Planeten gibt es bei uns im Sonnensystem, aber die haben es halt so ein bisschen in sich. Ja, haben wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen, was man so wissen sollte über unseren Morgenstern? Ich denke, wir haben die Sache gut eingekreist.
Ich denke, wir haben die Sache gut eingekreist.
Ja, dann sage ich vielen Dank. Für die Einblicke hier in die Venus, die sich ja eigentlich dem Einblick so wunderbar entzieht. Auf jeden Fall, da kocht sich ein Planet ganz schön was zusammen und trotzdem ist da irgendwie Windstille. Das hätte ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt erwartet. Ja, das war's. Raumzeit, 47. Ausgabe. Hier geht es dann auch bald weiter im Sonnensystem. Und dann schauen wir uns ein bisschen den Mars an. Bis dahin sage ich erst mal, bis bald und viel Spaß noch beim Durchhören aller ungehörten Folgen.